hey guys it is the 27th of July today my
name is just McDowell and he is a bunch
of you I sure hope you're attached to
that destiny character of yours because
Bungie wants you to hang out with them
for a decade the developer has confirmed
that their 10-year Lord of the Rings s
plan for destiny will involve your
existing guardian Bungie have said you
won't have to make a new character or
switch to another one when they release
expansions or wherever else they decide
to go with the franchise Destiny's
engineering lead Luke Timmons told
GamesRadar we certainly take it
seriously that destiny is a ten-year
thing adding your guardian will always
be there Destiny's next expansion the
taken King arrives in September an
officially licensed keyboard and mouse
for the ps4 has been announced and it
seems to be dividing you guys quite a
bit filled by Horry known for their
arcade sticks and primarily designed for
FPS fans the tactical Assault commander
for is a USB controller which aims to
imitate a pc setup by mapping the
DualShock 4's analog sticks to
traditional keyboard controls and the
mouse the playstation buttons are also
mapped on the keyboard as is the dual
shocks touchpad and buttons for walk and
snipe are respectively the peripheral
will support multiple controller
profiles and has thick LED backlighting
which if alienware has taught us
anything definitely makes you a better
gamer the kicker is that the keyboard
and mouse is listed at about 130 u.s.
dollars this obviously isn't the first
mouse and keyboard peripheral to ever be
released for consoles but it is the
first to be officially licensed by a
console makeup amuse thus mildly
concerning some steam accounts have been
compromised due to a security flaw the
security flaw was discovered earlier in
July and since then valve has been
resetting a number of stain passwords on
accounts with suspicious password
changes the floor itself could be
exploited by clicking on the forgot my
login details option after which a
hacker could enter the target steam
account name
to receive a randomly generated code to
their email usually you need to enter
the code sent to the email attached to
the username however this security floor
made it so one would only have to click
continue and be allowed to enter a new
password without entering any code at
all many users reported account hacking
last week and valve have apologized for
the oversight let me know if you think
destiny will last long enough to be the
decade-long franchise that Bungie want
it to be or not and why you can add two
games or we've got stories on a two
terabyte ps4 and the witcher 3 getting
new game plus mode that is all the good
stuff i have for you today as always let
me know what mattered to you and i will
catch you again tomorrow